Nói 5 tháng 10, tại Hà Lội chính vụ tối chức họ bảo thử gị tháng chính,
thân tin về tình hiện kích để xác hội chính tháng đầu năm 2020.
Theo bộ trường trủ hiện và phòng chính vụ trên văn sơn,
tăng trưởng dế đe bệnh bệnh bảo ước đặt trên tháng phần chăm,
tính chung chính tháng tăng trên bệnh bệnh tăng phần chăm, bám sát kịch bản đề ra,
cả bác của bực kinh tế để đều tăng chưởng tích cử,
với sấu địa phương tăng chưởng trên bùi phần chăm và mùi sấu địa phương tăng trên tháng phần chăm.
Kinh tế vị một ordent là phát được kiểm soch các cân đối lớn được bảo đam.
Chỉ số giá thư dùng CPE, bình quân chính tháng ước tăng trên bà phần chăm,
thuân ngăn rất chính tháng đặt một phẩy chính hai chựa tì đồng,
đơn chính tháng phần chăm dự tón năm, tăng bà mươi phẩy năm phần chăm sau với cùng ki,
tổng ký mời xuân nhập khẩu chính tháng đặt trên sấu chăm táng mùi tị Uat N,
tăng mùi bệnh phép phép phần chăm sau với cùng ki,
xuất siêu khoảng mùi bệnh tị Uat N.
Chỉ phủ đặt mục tiêu tăng chưởng dế bệnh cản năm 2020,
đặt tháng phẩy ba đến táng phẩy năm phần chăm,
khiểm soch lạo phát xế bốn phẩy nói phần chăm,
bảo đam ủ diện tinh tế vị mô và nâng cao đề sống dân.